[Musique]
le
bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8 politique
sur tv s 78 voici les titres de ce
numéro de décembre un nouveau maire une
nouvelle équipe pour coignières didier
fischer vient de l'emporter suite aux
divisions de l'ancienne majorité les
tensions les difficultés sont elles pour
autant un lointain souvenir les
prochaines élections municipales ne se
dérouleront qu'en 2020 attrape les
candidats déjà à se préparer guy
malandain au maire sortant annonce sa
candidature et du côté de l'opposition
des républicains cet autre manas roux
qui multiplie les initiatives de terrain
et puis nous reviendrons aussi sur la
colère qui s'exprime en ce mois à deux
êtres décembre celle des gilets jaunes a
notamment didier fischer pour soir
attend quelques instants vous allez
faire vos débuts au sein du conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous avez donc été élu maire de cette
commune est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
dire que la page des tensions des
dissensions et définitivement tourné une
page est tournée quand même un
aujourd'hui il faut quand même
reconnaître on revient à la sérénité
dans les services en ville donc là
effectivement on peut dire qu'une page
est vraiment tourné quand même
quelles sont vos premières mesures en
tant que maire à présent bah on va
travailler sur notre projet on a on a
énormément de réhabilitation à faire on
l'avait vu pendant la campagne
donc je pense que la première mesure qui
sortira je l'espère ça sera le ce sera
la mesure du gymnase la rénovation et la
réhabilitation du gymnase notamment la
maison si des jeunes enfin disons la
salle et c'est exactement pour pour les
jeunes qu'on essaiera de d'inaugurer en
juin si on si on est bien dans les temps
et puis et puis
or à la rénovation aussi au moins d'un
groupe scolaire dans là je dirai dans la
mandature dans les quatorze mois donc il
ya du travail quand même sur la planche
ça sera un mandat très court 14 mois
seulement les prochaines élections
municipales doivent se tenir en 2020
vous avez néanmoins le temps d'agir
on a trois mois on a trois mois en fait
pour lancer nos projets ensuite on a on
a une petite année pour les mettre en
oeuvre et vous le savez bien partir de
septembre ne pourra même plus
communiquer sur sur nos projets voilà
mais enfin un important c'est pas
tellement effectivement la communication
c'est que ça se fasse et que les
poignées rien puisse le vérifier en
ville sur les rapports avec l'opposition
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les rapports sont
sont sereins les choses ont apaisé je
reviens à cette question d'apaisement
parce que c'était attendu par les
habitants de banias
et puis c'était je dirais un des
objectifs aussi de notre projet apaisé
je pense qu'on va avoir des relations
tout à fait normal avec notre position
j'ai rencontré monsieur bousselham se
dirait on est convenus qu'en même d'une
attitude d'opposition constructive et
gérer les eaux dernier par exemple au
dernier conseil municipal
pratiquement toutes les délibérations
ont été approuvées en est une qui est où
l'opposition s'est abstenue et donc vous
voyez c'est quand même c'est quand même
constructif tout cela aujourd'hui ce
sera le premier conseil d'agglomération
auquel vous allez siéger en tant que
maire dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
on bosse je viens serein aussi ceux
observés moi je pars du principe déjà il
ya un temps d'observation quand même
avant de passer à l'action et j'espère
assez vite effectivement est dans
l'action aussi ici un communauté
d'agglomération je pose la question sur
l'état d'esprit parce que vous n'était
pas particulièrement favorable à un
rapprochement avec saint quentin en
yvelines
est ce que vous avez toujours en tête la
possibilité de quitter l'agglomération
de saint quentin nom n'a pas on n'a pas
n'a pas spécifiquement en tête la
possibilité la possibilité de quitter
l'agglomération bon c'est vrai qu'un
recours aujourd'hui quai pendant et qui
pourrait effectivement mais ça ça serait
le juge qui le diraient 'nous on
constate un état d'un état de fait nous
sommes dans l'agglomération tant que
nous y serons nous jouerons notre rôle
et nous avons bien l'intention de
participer au développement de cette
agglomération si coignard il reste bien
entendu à condition bien entendu aussi
que la place de coignières ils soient
respectées parce que c'était pas le cas
jusqu'à présent
bah non c'est pas je veux pas dire cela
ne veut pas dire cela mais je veux dire
dans cette continuité puisque ça fait
quand même que ça fait ça fait depuis
2016 que mes collègues du siège j'espère
que en plus que le maire de nouveau
maire de coignières au ras jédir elles
mêmes et les que l'agglomération
graphiste à vis du
du nouveau maire de coignières les mêmes
égards qu'il a eues avec l'ancien maire
de bagnères voilà c'est tout on va voir
déjà ce soir là une délibération je
crois qu'ils ont dansé le sujet en ce
soir il sera question du budget
forcément ce soir au cours de ce conseil
nous y reviendrons bien évidemment dans
nos éditions du journal dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons aussi sur la
contestation d'une partie des d'une
partie de la population française à
travers les gilet jaune et gilet jaune
qui se sont mobilisés sur coignières
justement et la municipalité les a
soutenus pourquoi voilà alors ceux qui
sont tenus en tout cas logistique
m'entendais attendait oui il fait chaud
la municipalité ne soutiens personne
la municipalité a veillé g ça a été un
des premiers gestes en tant que maire
par aller porter plainte à trappes pour
un accident dont mon premier geste a été
aussi de rencontrer les gilets jaunes
qui faisait du filtrage sous le pont de
nos bons mois j'y suis allé en tant que
nouveau maire en responsabilité pour
voir si toutes ces les choses se
passaient bien ci avait pas de
dégradations sur la voie publique
notre objectif c'était cela pas de
violence pas de dégradations sur la voie
publique
c'était l'objectif et on a mis à
disposition non pas toute la logistique
il faut pas exagérer on a mis à
disposition une benne pour que les
ordures en quelque sorte et les comment
dire les déchets potentiels ne soit pas
éparpillés dans la nature voilà c'est ça
la contestation est ce que vous la
comprenez en tout cas on la comprend
bien sûr bien sûr on la comprend et je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
la comprenne puisqu'il ya ya un soutien
à 70 72 % des gilet jaune
c'est compréhensible 1 c'est
compréhensible et je dirais que le maire
de coignières comprends tout à fait ce
titre est sûre mais le maire de poignard
n'a pas à prendre position comme cela
par rapport à une population qui pensent
se dire est ce qu'elle veut du mouvement
nous notre fameux rôle est de faire en
sorte que les choses se passent bien sûr
la commune qu'il n'y a pas de
dégradation de bien public et c'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya eu une évacuation
avec la police qui était une évacuation
qui s'est faite en douceur donc avec mon
autorisation d'envoyer le soutien avec
mon autorisation parce que effectivement
et la commissaire de police m'a expliqué
qu'il était nécessaire à ce moment-là
d'évacuer bon un certain nombre de gilet
jaune sont revenus ils sont visibles
mais il ne barre pas là la circulation
et ne serait pas la circulation
ils sont au carrefour des fontaines à
l'heure actuelle d'ailleurs j'irai
effectivement les rencontres et voir si
tout se passe bien
didier fischer nous avoir accordé
quelques instants avant que ce conseil
d'agglomération on retrouve ces gilet
jaune justement nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre pour les faire réagir sur les
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement et
puis juste après nous serons en plateau
avec othman nassr ou conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes à un
village de gillet jeunes à l'entrée de
la zone industrielle démarré à
coignières des citoyens avec des
situations sociales différentes tous
mobilisés contre la politique du
gouvernement
nous on commence à prendre racine
il ya une chose qui a apporté ce
mouvement et
et indirectement le président c'est une
solidarité
il a réussi à voile a rassemblé quand
même pas mal de demandes et on commence
à se créer une petite famille gilet
jaune et de ceux qui soutiennent à
travers un barrage filtrant les gie les
jeunes s'organisent pour faire vivre
leur mobilisation ce matin des élus de
coignières sont venus leur rendre visite
après l'installation d'une benne à
ordures par les services municipaux pour
voir quelles sont les quels sont les
besoins fait faire en sorte avant tout
que ça se passe bien aussi bien pour eux
que pour les automobilistes qui passent
s'il ya une volonté de donner la parole
aux français aux citoyens par
l'intermédiaire des mairies on le fera
enfin ça me paraît une évidence
augmentation de 100 euros du smic prime
d'activité comprise défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou suppression de
la hausse de la csg pour les retraites
inférieures à 2000 euros
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron est jugée insuffisante
beaucoup de personnes ici que j'ai
rencontrés m'ont bien fait comprendre
que voilà c'est ça ne suffit pas ça
suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir d'achat voilà c'est juste vivre
j'ai entendu c'est un premier pas qui
est intéressant maintenant il ya
tellement tellement tellement tellement
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés qu'au final en fait c'est du
vent je le prends comme ça
hier que quand on quand on est sur une
intervention médicale et qu' il ya une
hémorragie on met pas un pansement
on sort les gros moyens et on sauve la
personne cj les jeunes ont prévenu ils
sont prêts à passer les fêtes ici en
famille à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle des marais de coignières je
reçois à présent pour la suite de ce
sept suites politiques othman nasro
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition à trappes vous est aussi
président du groupe des républicains au
conseil régional d'île de france vous y
est aussi vice président chargé des
affaires internationales et du tourisme
mais c'est ce titre de conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui trappe ou le
maire et guy malandain a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'il serait candidat en 2020
est ce que vous aussi vous êtes candidat
le temps n'est pas du tout celui des
candidatures personnels ou des ambitions
individuelles moi vous le savez j'ai un
combat sur la ville de trappes qui est
inscrit dans le temps maintenant puisque
j'ai été candidat l'anr fois et me suis
engagé au lendemain des élections
municipales
quel que soit le résultat à rester sur
la ville et a continué à me
le travail de position qui fait
qu'effectivement je suis soucieux de
l'avenir de la ville et que je défends
un certain nombre d'options avec toute
une équipe qui est d'ailleurs une équipe
qui qui rassemble assez largement et qui
n'est pas une équipe partisane mais on a
un certain nombre de combats qui nous
tiennent à coeur et qui font que
l'avenir de trappes aujourd'hui il doit
se dessiner autrement donc les élections
municipales ne sont pas tout de suite
elles viendront un moment donné et puis
on verra qui est en capacité de
rassembler le plus largement possible il
ya beaucoup de talents sur cette vie de
beaucoup de gens qui ont envie de faire
avancer les choses sur trappe mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que les trappistes
vont avoir un choix qui est claire pour
l'avenir de la ville et c'est la seule
chose qui comptait moins j'y prendrai ma
part naturellement mais aujourd'hui on
est encore assez assez en amont de tout
cela pas de candidature personnelle mais
au moins vous avez lancé un appel au
rassemblement justement sur la commune
il ya des réunions publiques qui déjà
qu'ils commencent à s'organiser
le but c'est quoi c'est de préparer un
programme je les dis on a aujourd'hui
l'opposition municipale qui fonctionne
et qui défend un certain nombre d'idées
pour l'avenir de la ville
et naturellement on est aussi sur le
terrain et vous l'avez fait référence
moi j'ai fait un appel au rassemblement
de tous ceux qui croient encore qu'on
peut défendre la république attrapé
aujourd'hui le clivage aujourd'hui sur
trapil et celui ci il est sur la défense
de la république nous avons des défis
majeurs auxquels nous devons faire face
qui sont des défis du quotidien c'est
incontestable sur le cadre de vie sur
l'emploi sur la fiscalité je m'appelle
qu'on a des impôts locaux
particulièrement lourd sur la ville de
trappes
on a des défis en matière de sécurité et
puis encore une fois sur l'emploi et
notamment sur l'emploi des jeunes et là
dessus aussi
il faut pouvoir dire les choses de
manière structurée et une manières mais
de manière très forte le nécessaire
aujourd'hui n'est pas fait sur ces
sujets là mais encore une fois vous
voyez bien que là dessus on n'est pas
sur des débats de politique politicienne
une politique nationale on est sur des
sujets d'intérêts locaux et par rapport
à ça et bien moi je souhaite que tous
ceux qui veulent pousser dans ce sens là
pour donner un autre avenir à trappes et
pour défendre encore une fois la
république en termes de droits comme des
devoirs et bien que tout cela puisse
travailler ensemble et c'est de plus en
plus le cas cette commune qui
cristallise tout de même les appétits
ans l'adjoint au maire de trappes
le maire lui-même la france a soumis
aussi vous les premiers des défis en
tout cas pour qui que ce soit pendant
cette campagne ce sera aussi de motiver
les citoyens à venir voter la
participation est en baisse
régulièrement sur cette commune oui je
ne sais plus qui disait que attrape pour
tricher on ne bouderai pas lésions dont
les vides et effectivement on a parfois
l'impression qu'il ya une volonté de
dégoûter les citoyens de la vie
politique ce n'est jamais bon parce
qu'effectivement il faut que les gens
s'approprient au contraire la chose
publique c'est ce que nous faisons avec
trappe citoyens le groupe que j'ai
fondée il ya maintenant plus de cinq ans
et qui voit là s'est intéressée à
beaucoup de sujets de manière très très
local la qualité du logement social face
à un certain nombre des bailleurs
sociaux qui ne respectent pas toujours
les mecs je vais parler des impôts tout
à l'heure la question des rythmes
scolaires donc des choses très
spécifiques et qui ont ainsi redonner
goût à tout un tas d'habitants est bien
pour se préoccuper simplement de leur
quotidien
donc ça va être un défi naturellement de
mobiliser les gens mais encore faut-il
pouvoir leur présenter un vrai projet
vous l'avez dit donc l'on est engagée
dans ce travail là les habitants qui
viennent au conseil municipal voit aussi
que nous portons un certain nombre
d'idées avec les élus qui me font
confiance et qui m'accompagne je vous le
dis on a de plus en plus de gens
aujourd'hui de tous horizons de toutes
sensibilités qui nous rejoignent on va
continuer à défendre un certain nombre
d'idées et j'espère que c'est de nature
à redonner goût à la vie publique a
beaucoup de trac piste
vous étiez candidat lors du dernier
scrutin tout jeune candidat aujourd'hui
ce qui a changé c'est votre expérience
plus grandes aussi notamment au sein de
la région où vous êtes
je le rappelais vice-président ou encore
responsables de groupes également et
puis à cette expérience au sein de
l'agglomération avec le promo paul la
pépinière d'entreprises donc si vous
vous présenter devant les électeurs ce
sera avec un peu plus d'expérience
bah c'est incontestable que il faut
avoir de l'expérience pour gérer une
ville quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs est
naturellement la vie politique est aussi
un cheminement et moi j'assume d'être
allé aussi chercher de l'expérience et
de la crédibilité puisque effectivement
j'ai eu la chance de prendre des
responsabilités à ces jeunes la
sensibilité à ces importantes et donc
j'essaie aussi de me servir dans
l'intérêt de la ville vous avez cité
effectivement la région ile de france à
laquelle dans laquelle je siège et je
dirige le groupe majoritaire qui
composait de plus de 80 élus mais encore
une fois ça ça donne de l'expérience ça
donne de la crédibilité et puis c'est
important mais faisons aussi des moyens
d'agir et c'est important là on a
inauguré une très belle maison de santé
au mur izier attrape la maison de santé
du théâtre ou la région a financé à
hauteur de 260 milles euros donc si
c'est un motif de fierté
nous venons de finir la rénovation du
lycée matisse ou la région aussi engagé
12 millions d'euros
donc vous voyez que quelque part on a
les idées les valeurs qu'on porte et moi
je suis constant sur mes idées et sur
mes valeurs mais il ya aussi des projets
concrets qu'on peut ainsi réussir à
mobiliser en ayant de l'expérience et
mais aussi et surtout des partenaires je
pense à la région ou département à
l'agglomération de saint quentin pour
que tout le monde pousse dans le même
sens dans l'intérêt de la ville de
trappes et c'est aussi ça qui manque
aujourd'hui vous avez aussi essayer de
prendre la présidence des républicains
au sein du département des yvelines
c'était face à pierre bédier avec
alexandra dublanche ça n'a pas réussi
vous n'avez pas été élu néanmoins vous
sentez bien au sein de ce parti au sein
des républicains moi j'ai toujours ce
que j'ai juste le préciser tout de même
vous avez aussi rejoint le mouvement
libre lancé par un valérie pécresse un
oui où je suis proche de valérie
pécresse dont je soutiens la ligne
politique qui est équilibré qui a
compris un certain nombre de choses à
mon sens sur l'état du pays qui
proposent des solutions très concrètes
sans vouloir jeter de l'huile sur le feu
mais tout en assumant un certain nombre
de convictions et le travail que nous
faisons à la région je crois témoigne
aussi témoignent aussi de cela
s'agissant des républicains moi je suis
toujours dit j'ai une sensibilité à
droite je crois au mérite individuelle
je crois à la famille je crois la
responsabilité je crois au travail et
donc je suis constant sur mes valeurs et
je crois d'ailleurs que beaucoup de trac
piste aussi partagent ses valeurs
la question des étiquettes et des
appareils à moins d'importance moi j'ai
toujours eu de la distance aussi
vis-à-vis de mon parti jamais été dans
l'appareil du parti politique mais j'ai
ma sensibilité
jean suffirait donc j'essaie d'apporter
ma contribution il ya eu un débat
interne un moment de démocratie interne
j'aurais aussi les derniers étant
aujourd'hui il ya un président de
fédération qui a été éduqué le président
du département des yvelines qui fait
aussi un travail qui est reconnu par
tout le monde à la tête du département
donc voilà à chacun et à sa juste place
mais moi je continuerai à défendre aussi
des idées qui me tiennent à coeur
quand je pense la même chose que ma
famille politique je le dis et quand je
ne suis pas d'accord je le dis c'est le
cas aussi à l'agglomération de saint
quentin j'appartiens à la nouvelle
majorité et je suis très fier du travail
qu'on fait mais ce qui compte pour moi
encore une fois j'ai été élu à trappes
donc je défend naturellement les
intérêts de la ville de trappes est ce
que j'ai constaté aussi de ce qu'il faut
faire pour pour le quotidien des
trappistes et quel est votre point de
vue justement et si on se met du côté de
la ville de trappes sûr
radicalisation c'est départ en syrie
aussi là sur la ville de trappes il ya
des cas concrets il ya une soixantaine
de départ c'est un vrai dossier aussi
dont le maire pas uniquement le maire
mais dont le maire doit aussi se saisir
moi j'ai fait partie des élus qui ont
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur ce sujet
là dès le départ et beaucoup à l'époque
d'ailleurs m'avait reproché mal expliqué
que j'inventais des problèmes jeter de
l'huile sur le feu et moi je crois que
quand on a des défis à relever il faut
pas se voiler la face il faut nommer les
choses ça ne veut pas dire que ce
problème ne se pose quatre amis ils
s'opposent
il faut pouvoir l'assumer et si on ne
commence pas par dire ça on ne règle pas
le problème
et pendant longtemps la une omerta sur
tous ces sujets là de la radicalisation
du repli identitaire de la crispation
sur un certain nombre de sujets avec les
gens qui instrumentalisent aussi le fait
religieux pour en faire un instrument à
la fois de détestation de la france est
aussi un instrument de violence si on le
constate dans la poire constater
malheureusement il n'ya pas très
longtemps à strasbourg un nouveau et
donc trappe
on connaît cette réalité là et je vous
dis ça fait quatre ans que je le dis je
le répète je suis quelque part satisfait
de voir que quand même une prise de
conscience de ce phénomène là par les
autorités par l'état par le préfet des
yvelines qui vient d'arriver qui est
très mobilisé sur ce sujet là et je
souhaite que la municipalité prenne
toute sa part dans ce combat là et
comment on peut agir un maire justement
comment une municipalité peut agir bien
il ya tout un tas d'actions de
sensibilisation qu'il faut pouvoir mener
il y a aussi le respect strict de la loi
de 1905 qui formé seulement maintenir
sur le thème de la laïcité moi je le dis
puisque aujourd'hui cette municipalité
subventionne des lieux de culte ce qui
pour moi est en dehors de tout cadre
légal et je crois qu'en faisant ça on
vous jette de l'huile sur le feu parce
qu'on rentre dans des logiques de
clientélisme qui ne sont bonnes pour
personne y compris pour pour les gens
qui veulent pratiquer leur religion dans
des conditions dignes et c'est leur
droit mais il faut pas qu'on mélange la
politique et la religion et
malheureusement c'est encore un peu le
cas sur trappe
c'est bien pour ça que je vous dis que
le sujet ait raté la défense de la
république dans toutes ses dimensions et
naturellement sur ce sujet de la
radicalisation
il faut avoir une pensée pour les
familles qui ont vécu ce drame il était
souvent n'avaient aucun interlocuteur
et quand on vous explique que tout va
bien circulez il n'ya rien à voir ça
n'est jamais bon c'est vrai sur ce sujet
là comme sur d'autres
vous avez évoqué un terme clientélisme
c'est ce qui caractérise aujourd'hui
selon vous la politique menée attrape la
suge le sujet c'est de savoir si on veut
faire réussir la ville fait réussir les
habitants ou si on veut les maintenir
dans la situation que connaît la ville
avec des difficultés socio économiques
importantes
alors qu'on est dans une agglomération
dynamique je le dis parce que c'est
parfois mon sentiment est quoi mon stade
qui a parfois la volonté de ghettoïser
la ville moi j'ai coutume de dire que
dit que la ville est pauvre non la vie
elle est là les moyens la ville est
riche c'est les habitants qui
connaissent des difficultés
et c'est vrai que au titre de la
solidarité nationale la ville reçoivent
beaucoup de ressources financières de
transfert de fiscalité par d'autres
collectivités ce qu'on appelle la
péréquation
alors que ça ne profite pas
nécessairement aux habitants et c'est
cela aussi que j'appelle le clientélisme
c'est cette volonté finalement de se
constituer une boutique électorale et de
ne pas tirer vers le haut de ne pas
faire réussir les habitants on l'a vu
sur des rythmes scolaires
est-ce que des écoles de trappes
aujourd'hui ont les moyens ont d'autres
collectivités encore une fois ça n'est
pas une affaire d'argent puisque les
financements sont là c'est une affaire
de choix politiques de choix budgétaires
sur le développement économique il ya
énormément à faire moi je siège à la
commission du développement économique
l'agglomération j'ai présidé à la région
ile-de-france vie siège aussi à la ville
de trappes elle ne s'est réuni qu'une
fois en quatre ans donc il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de volonté politique d'aller
au delà sur ces sujets là moi je
reconnais au maire de trappes d'avoir
fait un travail important sur tout un
tas de sujets notamment durant ses deux
premiers mandats mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'avenir de l'avim
c'est de préparer la suite est passé à
la vitesse supérieure et on s'est occupé
des bâtiments fait le comprend la ville
est plus agréable c'était probablement
nécessaire mais on s'est probablement
pas assez occupé des gens la campagne
réellement pour vous commencerez quand
commencera quand vous êtes fixé un
calendrier savoir si oui ou non vous
seriez un candidat ou en tout cas tête
de liste moi je dirige l'opposition
municipale je le fais systématiquement à
chaque conseil avec constance et je
rends compte aussi aux habitants de tout
ce qu'on défend malheureusement n'a pas
les leviers d'action sur la ville les
ailleurs et on essaye y compris sur
trappe de faire avancer les choses il
dit avec l'agglomération avec le
département et avec la région où j'ai
pris les responsabilités que j'occupe
aujourd'hui
s'agissant des élections municipales je
crois que la campagne municipale
commence traditionnellement à la rentrée
2010 neuf donc concept en 2019 donc à ce
moment là on verra bien la tente des
habitants tout simplement ça durera ce
sera aux habitants de décider qui est
mieux placé pour porter l'alternance
mais fera que cette alternance attrape
aujourd'hui il est absolument nécessaire
mais quoi qu'il advienne vous serez
présent sur une liste quoi qu'il
advienne je mènerai jusqu'au bout mon
condamne pas de chef de l'opposition
municipale
mais ce qui compte c'est pas d'être
candidat sur une liste je le dis très
sincèrement moi j'ai pris des
responsabilités qui font qu'aujourd'hui
mon
mon obsession n'est pas d'être sur une
liste mais c'est en tout cas de faire en
sorte qu'on attrape il y ait une vraie
alternance et qu'on puisse faire réussir
la ville et on verra qui est le mieux
placé pour le faire et je les dis avec
une équipe qui soit d'intérêt local
un rassemblement large avec un vrai
projet une vraie crédibilité pour porter
l'avenir de la ville et on verra si j'ai
ma place dans ce dispositif là ou si mon
rôle sera simplement et bien d'appeler à
ce rassemblement c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
merci ottomane masque ou en phase de
rassemblement donc en vue de ces
municipales sur la commune de trappes on
est encore un peu le temps ce sera pour
2020 merci nos avoirs pillés suivi par
dont on se retrouve le mois prochain sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]